let's go next to our friend eric from
cancun we tried talking to eric last
week after
months off and his uh connection just
didn't work we couldn't hear him eric
are you with us today
as you can see i put next to my name the
topic i want to talk about and to
mention about idols i will ask you if
you heard the sound from eminem
sorry if i've heard the song stan by
eminem
i have i'm familiar with the song of
course
when
is it that that song is more like a
musical let's say about the
dangers of toxic fandom because
the song is that stan was very angry
that eminem didn't grow back because
he is a busy guy he should reflect that
i mean then have a hard time
crying back to every single fan and you
also struggle with that despite that you
have a dreadful night and
is it that it would be in that
those who are in a toxic fandom would be
feeling a boy
within them
and also then it would be that they need
something to fill themselves with
well eric you've really hold on let's
take it a piece at a time because
what you're throwing at me is so meaty
and substantive
i think you've identified quite a quite
a phenomenon which i think exists there
is definitely toxic fandom in the space
i inhabit you know on the internet
podcasting youtube
and i think you couldn't be more right
in your analysis a brilliant analysis
that some of these folks become toxic or
obsessed in their fandom
through these parasocial relationships
because it is within them that they have
a void they are trying to fill that
that's an excellent analysis eric
also then i'd rather see you as a friend
and as an idol because that would be a
healthier way to interact with
celebrities and also so i have my
personal agenda instead of wanting to
take over your life
wait did you say you see me more of more
as a friend than a son is that what you
said
no i see you as a friend more than an
idol oh because
because that would be a healthier way to
interact with celebrities and also so i
take my own life instead of wanting to
take over yours
right take control of your life eric i
love it what a message of
self-empowerment
i want to mention that this toxic
mindset would apply with relationships
with hobbies and with religion i will
tell you why
religion many want to go to the churches
and
talk to the priests because they want
answers and solutions for their problems
but morgan freeman when he was god in
bruce almighty he said that they forget
that they have the power to fix it
themselves and captain plans also said
that
aaron please eric do you have a
photographic memory
um
maybe it's because of my autism
let me finish
sorry about hobbies in the pixar movie
seoul there's a guy named joe gardner
who falls into the sewer and in
afterlife he meets a guy named win
moving says that when you are too
obsessed with a hobby or a passion you
become a lost soul moving was obsessed
with tetris
and in relationships i showed like
called stephen universe stephen went to
marry his girl connie but then connie
says that she wants to finish college
first and stephen was devastated so his
stepmom garnet tells him that although
stephen and econ would like to be
together they have individual lives and
also that a soulmate is a compliment not
a missing piece whatever is missing
steven's life connie cannot feel it he
has to feel it himself
eric if i may i have no idea what you're
talking about and that's okay because i
could listen to this stuff all day i
really appreciate you calling in eric
okay um one last thing i'm not saying
many quirky things in the show but i try
to give the best context i can so i
think it would be better to hear me out
or else i would feel like bru no no no
no i would feel like bruno
thank you so much and stay safe okay
all right there is eric from cancun wow
i am i am exhausted from that that is
really something that that is that is
extraordinary
one of our sponsors is called privacy
privacy is a totally free service that
i've been using for years privacy lets
me create virtual payment cards with one
click and when i use the virtual card
the money is taken out of my bank
account you can create multiple cards
delete them freeze them set a spending
limit on them let's say i'm signing up
for a free trial and it requires a
credit card privacy will autofill a
virtual card number and then after
signing up i can delete that virtual
card so i know i'm not going to be
charged again something really useful
and very practical or let's say i'm
ordering food over the phone
but i left my wallet somewhere i don't
have my real credit card on me i can use
a virtual card on my privacy mobile app
but really the best part is
you're not out there exposing your real
credit card number so you're not as
susceptible to data breaches and
identity theft
privacy is a totally free service and
you'll get five bucks to spend when you
go to privacy.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video